foreign
everyone welcome I'm Jack Van Horn from the
University of Virginia and I'm very proud to
welcome you to this edition of our 2020 to
2023 foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series this lecture series is supported by
uva's integrated translational Health Institute of
Virginia the U of A Brain Institute the
College of Arts and Sciences the school
of data science and through a grant from the
National Institutes of General Medical Sciences
since 2016 the foundations of biomedical
data science seminar Series has focused
on the use of data science methodologies
artificial intelligence deep learning and
statistical modeling as they pertain to different
themes in the biomedical and Health Sciences
this year's theme is data science and the public
health consequences of the covid-19 pandemic
where we will enjoy presentations from leading
thinkers about the issues promise opportunities
and hurdles associated with understanding the
secondary health effects of the covid-19 pandemic
these include delayed Health checkups
treatments mental health drug abuse
increased obesity and the long lingering health
effects associated with the SARS covid-19 virus
participants selected in our biomedical
data science Innovation lab program
leverage these presentations as vital material are
culminating in-person Grant project development
Workshop to be held at the lodge at St Edwards
Park in Seattle Washington in June of 2023.
today I'm delighted to welcome our speakers
senpay from the Department of Environmental
Health Sciences at mailman School of Public
Health at Columbia University at Columbia
Dr pays an assistant professor studying the
effects of environmental social and ecological
conditions on infectious diseases it develops
mathematical models and computational tools excuse
me to address surveillance forecasting and control
of both seasonal and emerging infectious diseases
Dr sen fun fact Dr sen likes traveling
and exploring different cultures and food
and continuing with our 2022-2023 biomedical data
science Innovation lab theme today's lecture is
entitled impact of covid-19 pandemic on influenza
the covid-19 pandemic has disrupted circulation of
many respiratory diseases including influenza
and in this lecture Dr pay will talk about
several studies which highlight the impact
of covid-19 activities in different countries
as always we are streaming this lecture
live and for recording via YouTube if
you're watching on YouTube thank you for joining
us our specially selected 2022-2023 biomedical
excuse me data science Innovation lab participants
and alumni are encouraged to submit any questions
via the chat feature in their Zoom sessions
where I'll synthesize these and ask them on
your behalf in the last 10 minutes or so of the
lecture and with that welcome Stan we're super
excited to hear about your presentation thank
you so much for your kind introduction um so
yeah thank you for having me here so today I'm
going to talk about impact of covid-19 pandemic
on influenza we will have a discussion of how
Copenhagen pandemic has changed the transmission
of influenza in the last few in the last three
years and also talk about what's the implication
for the flu Transmission in the next couple of
years so the talk will be um structured within
four different topics the first one I will broadly
talk about personal interactions and some previous
studies on this topic using data science and the
different um statistical and mathematical methods
and in the second part I will talk about empirical
evidence of showing how Covenant um how influenza
transmission was impacted by the covid-19 pandemic
in the last three years and third I will use an
example to show how we can use mathematical models
and the counter Factor simulation to study to
quantify the impact of covid-19 mpis on influenza
in different regions in the US and lastly we will
discuss and talk about what's the potential
impact on future influenza outbreaks caused
by the covenanting pandemic right okay let's
first start talking about password interactions
um so we all got common code every
year so on average each person will be
um will experience um two to three episodes
of um we call it acute respiratory infections
um which is also common uh common code we know
but we know that every uh behind every of those
illnesses there there's a pathogen right so um
there are a number of pathogens can cause common
code those include many endemic viruses which I
have a list here those are common seam viruses can
cause common code uh including influenza virus
a virus B respiratory Sensational virus or RSV
um seasonal coronaviruses there are four different
types rhinoviruses human metanimal viruses human
para influenza type one two three and adenovirus
and also others so this is a part of the list of
those endemic viruses that can cause common code
but also there's a novel varices are coming up
to cause severe here we call it pandemic right
so um those are the um um the most popular one
could be the the H1N1 in in 19 um 1918 right
that was like um 100 more than 100 years ago
and most most recently there's 2009 H1 and one
pandemic um but there's also other viruses from
um from even in from even we could even influenza
right if H5 and one H7 and nine those are highly
pathogenic even influenza which can cause severe
diseases but it's rare um and we also heard about
emerging infection disease about Source
in 2003 MERS and also Stars Kobe 2 which
is causing the the ongoing covid-19 pandemic
so among those um different pathogens people
have think about whether there's interactions
between those different viruses well one of the
um most well-known example is the interaction
between influenza and bacterial infections so
here it's not virus virus interaction but
it's it's a virus and bacterial infection
um here in this figure we can look at the number
of incidences caused by influenza uh shown in the
shown by the blue line and also the pneumococcal
pneumonia shown by the red line so you can see
both of them have very strong seasonality the
tends to peak in the winter times and have a
lower number of incidents in summer times but
if you look look at closer you will find it
whenever there's a peak for flu there's also a
little bump for pneumonia in incidence right so
this is one of the um example people have noticed
a long time ago they found that usually for those
vulnerable people they get infected by influenza
the mortality usually it's not caused by by the
flu itself but maybe the subsequent bacterial
infection and people have studied using mathematic
models and and datas to study those interactions
they found that flu interact the flu infection
actually can increase the susceptibility to
subsequent bacterial infection this is the
one very classical uh example to show how we
can um you know measure personal interactions
and when it comes to um virus virus interactions
particularly respiratory disease interactions here
is a very interesting study from UK and they look
at the um they look at the um the prevalence of
pathogens among patients in several hospitals in
glaslow UK from 2005 to 2013 and you can see for
some of the viruses here is influenza virus a
and the rhinovirus they tends to have opposite
phasing here when the flu is high rhinovirus goes
goes low so there's a correlation is negative and
also if you can look at influenza B and adenovirus
there's also a pretty strong inverse pattern right
when there's one is low the other is high but
at the same time there's some other pathogens
like RSV and metanemovirus you can see there's
a very strong similar seasonal patterns but
also some Peak at around similar time and also
PIV para influenza virus 1 and 2. so those are
all you know those data something will show that
probably there may be some interactions happened
across different viruses right between those
different vertices and then we when we think
about that we we always want to know what may
be the possible Pathways possible passwords
for personal interactions and here's a there's
a very nice review paper uh by uh papatovsky
and and colleagues uh and they summarize
the potential Pathways at different levels
um for her personal interaction and those
include a cellular level interactions uh host
level interactions population level interactions
right so I can briefly go through a thumb like at
the center level there may be computations for
the resources for virus replication if there's
one virus infected one cells the other virus
replication could be impacted right there's
also maybe cell damage caused by one virus which
can change the the virus replication of others at
the host level interaction it's mostly um mediated
by immunity or physiological changes for instance
if people get HIV uh it will you know weaken the
immune system which can lead to further infections
which otherwise would not be possible because of
the immune immune effect right and also there's
cross-reactive antibodies if a person got infected
by a very similar strain of virus there could be
cross protection happening so reduce the severity
or maybe the chance of infection for that and
there's also like interference signaling signaling
for physiological changes you can think about like
fever right fever is people have fever then you
have a higher temperature the replication of all
the maybe uh the viruses will be slowed down
not only the the pathogen causing the fever
um at the population level this is more related
to behavior changes which can reduce the contacts
and travels across different locations
right it slowed down the transmission at
the at the population level and also there may be
medication use and vaccination that could change
um you know the the likelihood of
of getting infected by other viruses
um there are many different methods we can try
to use data to identify personal interactions
um I would argue that the most important way to do
that is you can do some testing at the individual
level so probably you can have a monkey panel PCR
attack to see whether this person has this virus
virus right and uh and you can use those very
high resolution granular data coupled with some
regression models statistical models to quantify
whether there's a significant interactions between
different vertices and on the right is a study
from the UK I just mentioned a few slides ago
um that the the they use the data individual
level data which is really hard to collect
and very expensive I guess to quantify the um the
interactions and they found theirs their evidence
of strong negative and positive interactions
between different pathogens um but this data
is not all it's not always available right so
people have to sometimes have to use serverless
data which measures a Time series of disease cases
or other like maybe presented positive to do those
kind of analysis and people have used multivariate
base and hierarchical models uh to it is a
statistical model to this entangle the row you can
control a lot of variables to see whether there's
interactions happening but there's also other
people using a state space method reconstruction
um to you know try to use a framework of
causal inference to see if there is one
um there's a direct directional
interaction between different pathogens
um and also people can use other terms of
Time series method detecting causality or
correlation or even dynamical coupling
um between different time theories right
um and and lastly people can use some mechanistic
model you can assume there's interaction term in
your model and to fit the data feed the models
of data to estimate how large is interaction
there so there are pretty bunch of ways we can
measure interactions but not all of them are
working well given the data quality and all the
limitations we have in those modeling methods
so yeah so that's basically a brief overview of
what you know what people have done in terms of
quantifying personal interactions but here we
want to look at what what are the empirical
um data showing you know what happened for flu
during the last three years okay um the first
question is how can covet covid-19 impact fluid
transformation I I guess most of the important
um way we can think about is um that Source Kobe
2 and influenza share very similar transmission
routes um this figure shows the potential
transmission Pathways for Search scope into
and you can see many of them actually work for
flu and uh and because we we implemented very
strong mpis either governmental or voluntary right
um which has effectively reduced contact between
different persons so the chance of infection for
both flu and sort of covert 2 has been reduced
substantially and also there's a potential effect
of limited travel travel restrictions right you
don't have that much travel from one location
to the other which can limit reintroduction of
um flu virus from one place to the other there
has been some studies to look at co-infections
of flu and and influenza flu and Source Colby
too at the individual level there's one review
paper they gather a large number of studies and
they found that only about 0.7 percent of people
have co-infection confirmed by you know PCR
tests um it's so it's not very common to have
um co-infection but also there are some studies
using those data to show that influenza actually
is associated with a reduced rate of sarasco
B2 right but there's multiple different ways
you can explain how this Association happened
right and okay all right let's look at the real
world data in the US in the last in 2020.
so let me explain a little bit what we are
looking at here so we are looking at the curve of
percentage of visits for influenza like illness
it quantifies what's percentage of people going
to the hospital having symptoms like influenza
um so it's not like a very specific metric
for influenza because other viruses can cause
similar symptoms it's a symptom based but it
can give you a broader sense of what happened
um over the year what what general
level of respiratory diseases
and we can see their different curve from
different seasons and usually the ioi peak around
the winter time which you know we understand right
uh and also there here is a special case which is
2009 H1 and one pandemic season it pigs in the
Euro times very early uh in the season in the in
in in the autumn in the fourth time and here the
um the red red line here shows the level of ioi in
in 2020 right so this is um so you can see
during the during the covid-19 pandemic
actually the activity of IO is very low surprised
by NPI and maybe other factors so we are seeing
very small number of respiratory infections during
the Covenant during the first year of the pandemic
and there's also a study from Rachel Baker
and other colleagues as Princeton to look at
um what what is a positivity rate right you
test a number of samples you can look at what
percentage of those um samples have infected
by influenza this is a more specific Target for
influenza because you have to be confirmed by by
lab tests and you can see on the left we show the
um the percentage positivity in different states
over time and and the red the the vertical line
here shows the timing for the npis in the US
you can see after that you see a sharp drop of
positivity rate and those dotted lines showing the
previous Seasons the typical level of positivity
rate and and here's a nice color plot color map
shows you know you can see after um the MPI mpis
were implemented there's a sharp reduce of um
positively in all states of the US and the women
look at globally we can use data collected by The
Who flunet to look at um how flu activity changes
um during the covid-19 pandemic um so on the left
we show the um the positivity rate the positive
cases this is positive cases on the right we
show the num samples tested both in Northern
Hemisphere and and thousand chemistry because the
the winter the seasonal is different right so it's
so you have to look at differently and uh you can
see before the covid-19 pandemics it's very clear
seasonal pattern in this in the winter you have a
lot of cases but here if you look at the number of
cases after covid-19 pandemic essentially it
goes to very low level right it's not there's
some data here it's very low and I'm showing
a zoom in plot here um the number drops from
I think maybe the order of like tons of Southern
to a few hundred so like maybe only one percent
of previous level and is it people may ask is
this because of people are testing less during
the kubernetes pandemic actually it's not
because here you can see the number of tests
it's still very high right it's testing a lot of
people but you don't see any of those positives
and uh and there's some other
studies looking at covid-19
um look at flu activities in different countries
specifically on the left on the left you can see
this is work uh from China um those blue line and
the black line shows that um the positivity rate
in the two seasons prior to the covid-19 pandemic
but then uh after npis implemented in China
um also the positivity drops significantly it's
much lower than previous season and also you can
look at data from South Korea also has very
strong MPI at the beginning right and those
data those dotted line shows the previous
seasons and the um the the black line shows
the data in 2020 so there's a very strong
suppressional flu activity in South Korea
okay now we look we have a look at
some population level indicators of
um what happened for flu during the covenanting
pandemic then we can think about how covid-19
pandemic shift the evolution of flu activity
then we need to look at the sequence look at the
lineages and Sub lineages of flu viruses um there
are four circulating major circulating flu sub
lineages I'm showing here this is from a beautiful
realization from work from Hong Kong team
um so they are taking the sequencing data from
gisaid genset which is a platform people upload
your sequence data right uh and uh
we are looking at a H3 and 2 ah1 and
one those are two major circulating viral
strands and also B Victoria and B Yamagata
um different colors means different different
strands you know depending on how you classify
them right uh and uh and the the width of this
band shows the number of samples within the data
um so you can see clearly
after after the spring of 2020
I mean you are losing a lot of diversity only
most most of them actually disappeared in the
samples you can only have a very small number of
active circulating lineages happened observed in
this in this big database and and surprisingly
there's a has been no B Yamagata um sub lineage
observed after spring of 2020. so you can see it's
actually the NPI was so strong that it removes a
lot of those circulating you know strands and only
remain some some of the major ones probably in
some locations with a higher transmission or maybe
denser population can sustain their transmission
there and this can be better um seen by looking
at the phylogenetic trees for the four different
subtype sub lineages right so um you will see a
lot of diversities of the strengths before the
pandemic and after that you will see a lot of them
they just disappear only have a very small number
and only a couple of them survived uh entering
into um into um into 2020 uh after and you can see
he's strikingly you can see the the B Yamagata is
just disappeared there's no uh something of that
um so this has a pretty strong this I mean
this has also very pretty strong geographical
patterns we can see here um this is also from
the same paper from Hong Kong's which shows
very very informative how um how the evolution
of influenza has been changed by the NPI right
um so for each of those sub lineages we have we
have a comparison for pre-cover 19 data and the
covenanting data this is from April 2020 to
July 2021. um before that you can see there's
a lot of diversity antigenic diversity different
strands circulating around different areas of work
um like for H3N2 right but after that you will
see um you can see the the majority of the strands
they just disappeared and only had two major
strengths circulating one mostly in Southeast
Asia and South South Asia the other one is in west
of Africa um so so the transformation has been
largely localized because the connection between
different locations has been strongly reduced
there's no traveling um across different locations
there's very limited traveling actually so you you
will see there's a very isolated evolution of that
and this pattern also shows for other sub lineages
here is the figure comparison for H1 and one
right you can see it used to be you know across
many local many countries around the world but
now you can only observe some major ones in West
Africa those are hot spots transmission and for
B Victoria also you use you can see the similar
patterns for the B and Regatta you literally
didn't see any samples after the covid-19 pandemic
and there's there's a lot of discussions
on whether there's a real elimination of
B Yamagata stream um and this is because there
are several reasons we can we can think about
why that could happen the first one is um you know
after the covid-19 pandemic with those strong mpis
um flu viruses can only survive in
several hospitals some of the places
there's a small population may not be enough
just to sustain those transmission and also
um the survival of specific strength is
affected by the by the antigenic diversity
um so according to who as of February 2020 um
there there were there were no confirmed B yeah
detection since March 2020 so this is a huge you
know information right and the suppression of B
Yamagata could be because of covid-19 actually
coincide with a period of low incidents and low
antigenic diversity for BM Garden even before
the covid-19 pandemic the the incidence of
being a God is very low and also the energetic
diversity is very low so you're very similar
um and also um probably is because of people
discussing about this probably is because
of prolonged use of a well-matched influenza
vaccine because in previous Seasons the matching
um for for the big Yamagata while the component
in in flu vaccine is is very well because there's
there's no a lot of antigenic diversity so there's
still a active debate on whether there's a lack of
detection or is true Extinction which has may
have some explications um um what we want to
choose in the in in in in in the students in our
um flu vaccine right and and yesterday actually I
took a look at the data from whonet on the top we
show the data from from the end of 2019 and until
the most recent data you can see the they have
different strands color coded here uh you know
this period mostly in 2020 and early 2021 there's
almost nothing reported very small number of cases
but if you specifically look at B Yamagata um it's
dropped significantly uh in the spring of 2020 and
then there are some sporadic reporting there but
it's not clear whether those are you know actual
transformation or it could be some extent even in
this season it's a very small number lower than 10
um 10 samples submitted across the
whole world so it's very interesting
to look at how whether B Yamagata
will will get back or is actually
um eliminated all right then I think the
other topic we want to cover is to use
we know that there's a lot of reduction of flu
activity but can we quantify the the reduction
can we get an exact number of how many infections
were not happen because of Kobe 19. but however
doing this actually is not an easy task um there
are a couple reasons a couple of challenges for
doing this the first one is there's strong
variation in pick timing and pick intensity
across different seasons as you can see from
the earlier figure I showed the the curve for
different seasons even though people know that
flu typically peak in the winter time but if the
peak timing can be vary and the pick in terms of
the very different according to different factors
so you just cannot take the historical average
and to look at you know the difference between
the observed and historical average because
the historical average is not accurate for
what happening in that season specific season
and second one is the types and subtypes which
are having very different seasonal phasing
uh not very different but you know there's
some difference so we need to estimate A and B
separately um and then we can think about there
are many factors uh different uh there are many
many difference in the geographical locations
right for instance there's some Regional Dynamics
differential mpis implemented uh and also maybe
the initial sustainability could be different at
the beginning for flu right so we want to estimate
those numbers for each region in the U.S uh and
here in this study we we use the HH region HHS
region region level aoi plus which is a metric
we use we multiply influenza like illness by
Laboratory test positivity rate for influenza ah1
and B we we are not considering H3 and 2 because
there there were basically no H3N2 in that season
um so um we will mostly focus on ah1 and 1 and B
so how do we simulate um transmission of influenza
and people have been using mathematic models we
know a lot about the SAR model during the last
few years right so a similar idea that we can use
those type of dynamical models to simulate um the
um the influenza like illness plus signal we have
here and this is a model structure here it's a
SARS model uh it's susceptible infected recovered
and susceptible again model but the transmission
rate here beta is changing over time we impose
some seasonalities uh using humidity because we
know humidity can change the transmission rate for
influenza in winter when the low humidity you have
a higher transmission so you can see more cases in
Winter and this is a very simple model right um we
want to calibrate the model to the real world data
using using mcmc method to estimate parameter
initial conditions in different locations
okay so before we do anything to the using the
real world data we first want to see whether this
model can actually capture the transmission
and the disease data right so we did some
retrospective forecasting and feeding uh using
historical data here uh so in those places you
can in those figures uh we are feeding the data
to um ah1 and B from previous season this is a
national data but we also have Regional data
uh and uh the blue dots are the reported data
actual observation and the uh the gray area
The Gray Line is the mean prediction a mean
fitting and the green area are the 95 confidence
interval so you can see mostly the the model can
you know can reproduce the general um
seasonality and an epidemic curve here
um and then we apply the data apply the model to
the real world data in 2019 and 2020 season so you
can see here I'm using the um uh the vertical
dotted line to show March 15th that's the week
when there's a strong um I think lockdown happened
in New York City and also in other locations
um we fit the data until this 10 point you we
only use the data before this time point to fit
the model and we can project model into the future
to see what if there is what if there were no npis
um you know how many cases were reported um right
so it's it's basically a counter Factor simulation
showing that okay we we assume this model can
reasonably represent a full transmission and
we want to see without any interventions what
will happen in the spring of 2020 and then you
can compare those projections with those actually
observed data point here um so you can see there's
some difference here right but because of the
NPI happened at the tail of this season so the
absolute number of reduction actually is not
that much right and this is particularly true
for B Because almost it's already goes very
low by the time of people implementing mpis
um then we can one of other reduction of influenza
incidents compared to the predictive values within
10 weeks after March 15 2020 right it's a
long sentence but I basically you you take
the predicted value you minus the observed value
right that's the absolute difference between the
predicted and The observed and then you you can
you can divide this number by the predicted value
so you will see the percentage drop during
the 10 weeks period after lockdown and and we
saw very you know some variations um in different
regions in the US can see some of them they can be
um reduction by maybe 70 percent but
some of them they can be up to 90 percent
um and for B it's even even larger some of
the some have a low of 30 reduction probably
already the the activity very low but some
of them some locations you can see there's
reduction of up to 90 so it's a so there's
some geographical distribution Happening Here
and we didn't include Region 2 here Region 2 is
including New York's New York state New Jersey and
also somehow Virgin Islands so I don't know how
the classmates is very different but the classes
are somehow together in the region too um but we
didn't include that because we found there's um
abnormal reporting of influenza like like earnings
in region two so this is data from the flu view
um the percentage of people percentage percentage
of people going to see doctors with flu influenza
like illnesses and you can see after the
lockdown here you actually see a lot of more
reporting of influence influenza like illness
in region two mostly driven by New York area
um I think that's probably driven by the
behavior General people get a panic they
want to go to hospital to see um if they got
coveted or flu or other respiratory diseases
um and uh and then you can see at the bottom
we show the um the number of positive specimens
uh collected during this period and you can see
there are actually no increased number of specimen
tested during this period so I I mean that's
why the reason you know when we qualified those
you have to consider some issues within the data
there's a number reporting there so we eventually
did not include this region in our study and uh
and lastly uh you want to I mean the the last
slides I show we quantify the number of reduction
in terms of incidents um but what is reduction of
transmission rate beta in the term right so we can
vary beta uh by some multipliers and you can find
the best feeding data and compare that with you
know to see which is best fitting and to explain
um the observation of incidents after lockdown and
we found that um the transmission rate uh has the
transmission rate has dropped significantly across
different locations and in the US for each one is
dropped by half or B drop by maybe one third so
those are some some math some methods we can use
to quantify um the impact of um the reduction
the impact of covid-19 on on flu transformation
all right so yeah those are all all the
data we have in the past we do some analysis
retrospectively but another big question is what
will happen for influence what what are those
means what does this thing what what do those
means in the future for um for flu outbreaks um
and people have done this also right you can use
the model for instance here in in our paper uh
we have projected the model into the future using
the fitted model giving some predefined scenarios
right for instance here we are assuming okay
how about we maintain the same level of control
for 1.5 years and and then you lift the control
at this point what you would say in in the next
few years right so we are having we are trying
different levels immunity like this is means
the immunity for influence that can last for two
years this was three three years and four years
um um we can try different scenario to see what
is look but generally you will see is after
um after while two years of no flu activity
um usually once there's a remove of mpis you will
see a huge Spike after that in that season uh and
that will have some Ripple effects on seasonality
here right so you have to take some time to
reach back to the just you know this typical
seasonal pattern and there should be some and
this effect depends a lot on on the the lens of
immunity for influenza and there's another study
um you know I just mentioned from Princeton the
um they look at the accumulation of Summer people
right during this time it goes much higher so
usually in the previous season when there's a
new infection there's a lot of people will bring
down and then during the summer it goes up if you
want to goes down there's a seasonal pattern here
but in the last in the last two well two years
when there's no infection there's a buildup of
the subtle people so so once there's a removal of
those control measures you will see a lower Spike
here which is far higher than previous Seasons but
here they are modeling RSV another respiratory
virus which is very also very important
um pathogen but the basic Sim I mean the basic
message is similar you would expect some huge uh
spikes uh if you suddenly remove the um the mpis
and then let's look at what happened now it's like
2023 you know people um have dropped all those
you know most of those npis in I guess maybe in in
the last two years so uh so you can look at what
happened in the season of 2022 and 2023 I was last
um last winter we have seen a very large and
early um outbreak for influenza as is for ioi
um and uh usually at this time you don't see that
high activity because you need to go really go
into the into the winter to see the ramp up of
influenza outbreaks but in last season we are
seeing very early onset of flu activity and
also the the peak is pretty high um as I said
this is ioi it's not specific for influenza
but it has some indications of what happened
and then here there's there was an article
from New York Times they're talking about
the the tripod damage happened in the winter of
2022 they look at covid-19 RSV and flu activity
and here they are using hospitalization data
so which is more specific it's definitely a
slow flute because it has to be confirmed for
flu um and you can see uh covid-19 actually is
lower than previous season because you know um
the it's Omicron and uh and and uh and there's
a very low lower severity so there's a smaller
number of people going to the hospital and RSV
goes much higher is you know those lines are
the previous historical data it surpassed I
think it's the highest level in the last 10 years
probably is is and most of the hospitalizations
are actually for young children who have never
experienced RSV before uh and for influenza
it's much higher right it's a kind of like it
surpassed the hospitalization caused by Hoven 19.
um so we do see there's a large rebound so
the model kind of tell us the the Quant the
quality result that there will be some
severe outbreaks happening um after NPI
were implemented but what will happen this year
or next year um is still not very clear I guess
um another big topic here is a disruption on
virus Evolution right so we can see there's a
huge reduction in antigenogenic diversity uh and
which brings in a lot of uncertainty in how the
flu virus will evolve in in the next few years in
in the future the first we can see you know the
answering comes from the isolated geographical
distribution and those may lead to Independent
Evolution right so there may be some you know um
that's my location specific students happened uh
appear and then there's because of different
prior infection history there may be a diverse
population immunological landscape maybe in
different in U.S in China in different countries
they have very different they will impose
different evolutionary pressure on the on the
evolution of viruses and uh and then you can think
about there's a huge difference in vaccination for
flu so that's another level of um uncertainty you
don't know what are the pressure of um for for
evolution impulse by vaccination right and this
has a very you know significant impact for so for
for the vaccination vaccine viral selection here
because if you you found usually now we are using
very similar um formula for for the whole for the
whole world but if you found that okay maybe this
area has a very specific viruses strength for
this location how you can you know um desire
more effective formula for the vaccine you have to
consider those right if there's a co-circulation
of antigenically distinct lineages it has a much
imposed Challenge on how you select the formula
the virus in in the vaccine and the other thing
um the other topic I will briefly touch on is um
because of the there's a lack of uh flu outbreaks
in in 2020 2001 um it may have some implications
for our children because they don't have
initial exposure to influenza at their early age
um there's concept that they call it immunological
imprint imprinting or original antigenic scene
now this figure shows some of the ideas uh I'm not
expert on this but I I can generally talk about
what the general idea here right so the x-axis
shows age of the person and the waxes shows the
severeness of disease after infection by influenza
right at a young age if you if the person got
impulse 2 H1N1 and there will be immune response
to developed to H1N1 right the second time if
this person imposed to H1N1 the similar to be much
lower because there's already some memory B cell
T cells to reduce the severity of the disease
right and later if there's a slightly different
you know this exposure to h5n2 right this is
very there's one similar approaching uh there
um so there could be uh might be cross-protection
because of similarity but if there's a primary
infection with H3N2 which is totally different
virus then you know uh this person will be
primed to the first exposed virus for the rest
of the life but as a cost of maybe have a bad
um immunity response to another strand of
influenza so you would have seen a very
severe disease probably after infecting by another
strength um so um so yeah that's why you know a
lot of people they they think about what immunity
landscape across different look across different
locations they will see the they would look at
the burst cohort when those people when the people
were young what kind of Errors they were exposed
to right so this is figure from a review paper uh
so uh this uh this shows a time from late 19th
century to 2018 and and on top shows the major
circulating uh strands of influenza right and you
can see different people when they were born they
experienced different viruses and they may have
a a better immune response later in their life to
the first strand they were exposed but if there's
some other new viruses uh whereas students uh
infected them they may have a bad response there
and that's why there's some their study looking at
um this effect you see that maybe the middle
aged individuals may be in the Perpetual state
of H3 and to influenza virus sustainability
because the you know those people were born
around this age they were exposed to H3 and two
at that time but now I think the Contemporary
H3N2 is a little bit different from that
so they can respond pretty well to that
stream but if there's a new for the Contemporary
it's written too they may not they have a like
um lower um worse immunological response so
yeah I think that's probably uh I will stop
here and we can I think there's a lot of unknowns
in the future about what happened what will happen
in terms of flu uh outbreaks I'm just listing
some of the literature and some of the papers
talk about this topic and I hope people here
they can you know get interest in this topic
and try to use data and modeling and different
method to study this and try to see whether we
can help people to reduce the uh the burden
of influenza in them in the future all right
I just recap what I talk about first and we
talk about the passive interactions some of
the method used in the previous studies and
we look at the empirical evidence of covid-19
pandemic during the last three years and we use
the model study to Showcase how we can quantify
um impact of mpis on covid-19 in the US across
different locations and lastly we talk about
several factors we still don't know the impact
on future influenza outbreaks so I think I'll
just stop here and take some questions thank you
so much and thank you very very much I was really
intrigued there when you were kind of touching
on some of the kind of the the genetic influences
that may be affecting the viruses making them more
susceptible or making people more susceptible to
them and I noticed in in several of the studies
that you were talking about you were talking about
um kind of correlations between viral outbreaks or
viral exposures where there was kind of a temporal
you know as one p heat so did another one or
rather one peaked and another one went down
because people weren't as exposed I was kind of
curious whether or not there is over a long time
as these viruses kind of are in the population
with those things happening are there any Trends
towards like co-evolution of viruses that um kind
of make either of them stronger is do they reach
any sort of an equilibrium where they just kind
of are constants in the population at particular
levels or are there any opportunities for viruses
and the culture of the people that they infect to
co-evolve as well does that make sense yeah
I think um I think that makes sense but I'm I
haven't seen a lot of studies on that topic I mean
because usually there are a lot of factors shaping
the um the evolution and you know and also the
transmission at the population level right I think
the key Point here is we are lacking of those
high resolution data to answer those questions if
someone can provide maybe individual level data uh
you know longitudinal so you can better understand
what's going on there I think definitely can
use a mathematical model to you know to look
at whether There Will Be steady state or whether
there be some pattern there but it's it's very
important to use those detailed data to to answer
those questions right yeah I I agree and you know
one of the things I always kind of puzzling
on while you were giving your presentation is
you had a couple of maps that are showing the you
know the maps of the United States showing the uh
outbreak concentrate operations for these various
viruses I was kind of wondering like when we were
having the covid-19 pandemic the Johns Hopkins
people got very famous for having their coveted
19 map and whatnot and it occurred to me that
you know we have maps on our phones right and
we get a weather we've got I've got a weather app
I've got Google Maps I've got you know several
different mapping things that why don't we have
like a virus map that's really anywhere you are
in the world much like Google Earth or Google Maps
you'd be able to go and see what the kind of what
the weather report is the viral weather report for
your particular area anyway while you were talking
I went and looked it up I found this one called um
flu star which is a uh an app that you can get for
your phone um but it's it it's it's kind of still
kind of low res but you can also Imagine That
the viral transmissions and its locations and
concentrations are very much like the weather
and as we move around we're moving around in the
space that the virus moves around into much like
you know we can expect tornadoes in Oklahoma
and we could expect a hail storm somewhere else
that uh these would be different forms of viral
weather if you will and I'm curious if you think
that there might be something like that for the in
the entrepreneurial minded maybe they could pursue
that yeah I think that's a the question relevant
to disease surveillance right so currently the
sermon has mostly come from Healthcare Systems you
go to hospital you get tested they report to the
CDC or on that I mean so this this makes the whole
process very slow I think reporting for fluids
have a lack of two weeks you don't you don't get
the real-time data yeah so the other option is
citizen science I think there are some apps called
Blue near me so you can report symptoms or any
people you know infected by some viruses right
so you can report those to there so you will see
um you know what what the general prevalence
across different locations but that has a have
it yet because you don't have the Laboratory test
right you don't know what virus it is you can only
know this person has a code it could be could
be clove it could be a flu could be other things
um so yeah and also I mean that's
really popular to do some have some like
um mobile devices people can try track you know
you have those fancy Apple I I watch right if
you can use those devices to collect data uh that
would be fantastic but I think the key Point here
is whether do you want to know the resolution
of which virus causing um the illness if you
only only you want to report illness I think it's
possible to do as long as a lot of people want to
do it um yeah yeah and you know it's funny I was
thinking as you were just talking about uh the one
where you can report you know people who may have
the flu near you I could see the downside of that
is that you it'd be like swatting your neighbor
right if you didn't like them you could like oh
that person has the flu and you could report them
and be mean to them um but on the other hand I was
thinking that another way that could you know
one could enact something like this would be to
put monitors in say um monitoring sewer systems
for example um where you could actually detect
the you know the presence of the virus or which
virus it is which was present and you know most
places with a sewer system would be able to if we
had a device that you could install and it would
then report uh the presence or absence of various
viruses and whatnot that would at least give us a
hint of what's out there and where is it and in
what concentration and what to watch out for and
could be done in real time without having to ask
people yeah yeah and he's faster I mean with water
services is very important right now I think
starting from Kobe and people doing a lot of
those and actually there was a paper published I
I was thinking to put it here uh the the look at
the waste of water data they sequence they look
at a bunch of respiratory diseases in the data
and they found the some of the common respiratory
devices were the RV RNA copies are lower during
the kubernetes pandemic it was just showing that
this could be a possible way you can detect uh
it's passive you don't need to get concerned uh
you know it's earlier than symptoms right you you
don't you don't have to wait until there's there's
a symptom and uh there's a lot of advantages there
but also there are some challenges for that
because you have to link I mean if you only
need to to know whether there is or not it's easy
to do right if you find it there isn't yes but if
you know the quality you know how what does this
number mean at the population level uh there has
yeah it is a little bit challenging to do that
because you know all the factors coming into that
yeah yeah and I'm thinking that the the modeling
becomes so much more than just looking at a time
course right you're also looking at the change
in space of the con where's the concentration
Peak at that particular moment it's going to
move right in which case it probably has to
be with something like you're solving a second
order partial differential equation or series
of them uh in order to model the the patterns of
the interactions between the viruses as well you
know in space as well as time and that becomes
very computationally challenging how then you're
absolutely right if there's people in the
loop who have to give consent or have to be
monitored you know by the time they're reporting
it you've missed a lot of time it would need to
be something that one would have at you know
you'd have in in Wastewater locations you'd
have Samplers that would report in real time
and much like a weather station on the top of
a mountain someplace you know scattered around
the country one could then interpolate between
them and use them as fixed points for you know a
partial differential equation modeling yeah yeah
of course it sounds easy when I say it
but I'm sure it's a lot harder than that
um what sort of things what sort of skill sets do
you see data scientists needing to be able to help
develop these models and make them something that
could be actionable like this well there are a
couple things if you um if you want to focus more
on the you know the interaction part I think data
science should be able to understand um you know
some of the typical methods you use to statistical
methods to disentangle interactions between time
theories those are the the techniques I think is
important to know but also I think it's important
to know to have some biological background about
how those pathogens interact whether what are
the potential Pathways to do that and if you
want to do something operational you want to
you know push something uh to real to use in
real world then that's a big question because
you have to understand all the limitations in
implementing those things like what the data
limitation there will be reporting delay there
will be missing data there will be uh you know
we revising um you know it's a lot of uncertainty
coming into this and also whether how you can try
to convince people to use it uh especially how
do you work with maybe Public Health agencies um
those are something pretty important but I think
I think this is a kind of interdisciplinary it
really depends on which which perspective you want
to focus on um but I do think it's important to
know both the data and and the biology and the uh
um you know of the question I think that's
super important because the accuracy of your
model you may be able to get some numerical
accuracy but there's also the the uh kind of
construct reliability of the measurement right is
it actually reflective of underlying biology or is
it some you know Epi phenomenon and you're just
really good at detecting it yes yes exactly yeah
any parting words uh about uh you know what
what's coming next for this kind of modeling
of flu or covid or other viruses that we have
yet to be exposed to um oh this is a pretty big
topic right so a lot of people working on this
actively working on this and it involves a lot
of uh fantastic research questions I think um
I think a lot of people talking about involving
human behavior into into disease transformation
right so how do you because a lot of those
interactions I described was immediated by human
behavior you reduce the reduced contact then
um then you will reduce the transmission multiple
pathogens not just the flu or covet I think that's
something you know if you can get a better
measurement of how people interact how people
sleep together and uh without violating some
privacy issues that will be very very helpful
and I do think there are some data starting to
you know to to to do that uh and uh for for other
questions because I'm not working on like real
biological questions uh and uh you know those
immunological questions um I probably should
not like talk about those topics but I think
mostly in our research in my research um in
terms of data science I think measurement of
human behavior is is very important and how
you how you use that data to inform disease
transformation and evolution that's very important
topic right now that's fantastic well sen thank
you so much for sharing your work with us in in
these ideas about uh you know viral transmission
not just covid but those other viruses those pesky
viruses which are out there that uh you know we're
sure to uh experience once again here uh once
uh this summer is over and flu season comes up
again but some thank you so much for sharing this
thank you so much for giving us uh some insight
into uh how best to model this and uh your work is
fantastic um everyone have a wonderful wonderful
weekend and I encourage you to uh tune in next
week when we have our final biomedical data
science uh seminar series and uh we'll uh see you
then have a wonderful weekend thank you again Sen